hey what is up guys M can be HD here and
I'm shooting with wired today and we're
gonna show you a couple dope tech gift
ideas for this holiday season first what
I'm gonna show you is called the Fitbit
charge HR so as a dedicated fitness
tracker this guy's gonna show you stuff
like the time and how many steps you've
taken and also your heart rate which not
every fitness tracker does they get
stuff like the amount of distance
traveled and calories burned so pretty
sweet as far as wearable tech goes all
right next thing I want to show you guys
is actually a smart phone you can pick
it up at your local Verizon store and
it's got a couple pretty sweet features
that I really like actually it's called
the droid turbo 2 so it's headlining
feature is actually the display up front
not only is it really big and bright and
crispy it's also a durable one it has
shatterproof technology but that's
probably for another video so a big
phone also means a big battery and this
guy is no exception in some cases inca
last you up to two days and if you like
this lover back you can do that but it's
also super customizable you can jump
online to moto maker which is motorola
customization suite to see all the
different design options you have for
your phone so you can go with the wood
back or a different color if you want so
that's the droid turbo 2 now another
thing that'll actually pair really
nicely with it is this bluetooth speaker
right here this is the bose soundlink
mini and something like this will give
you really loud sound but in a really
compact package so you can toss this in
a backpack it'll pair via bluetooth you
can take your music wherever you want so
that'll do it
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace